49ers are gonna take penny sewell so
it's either gonna be three or four for
the 49ers but what the falcons do with
four let's assume the 49ers exercise the
pick
the falcons can go so many different
directions
and and they've done a great job of
keeping their cards close to the best
trade down take a quarterback take the
best-known quarterback on their board
it it really
is uh going to going to be interesting
to see what they do that'll give us the
first tangible look in how arthur smith
and terry fontenot envision that
franchise moving forward the next couple
of years at the most important position
on the field will it still be matt ryan
or will they commence the process of
getting a young quarterback ready
mike figure out right now the difference
between
taking a young quarterback with a rookie
contract for let's say five years
including the fifth year option figure
out the average cap number of that
player
over the next five years
versus the average cap number of matt
ryan
over the next five years if they were to
resign him let's say at the end of next
year or or whenever you know and if you
did that to me
one of the factors that you must
consider
if you do take a quarterback at number
four
is that it means almost certainly that
matt ryan's gonna play probably two more
years for your team and then he's gone
so
the last three years
of the five-year uh number for the
rookie
what would it average let's say maybe
about
9 million 10 million including that
50-year option
but
that is one thing that i believe instead
of 9 or 10 or 11 million if you sign
matt ryan then you're averaging in the
in the 30s at least
and so that's one thing that i think the
the falcons have to consider
but the one other thing that that i was
told
by people who know the falcons is that
arthur smith
absolutely categorically is not going to
reach
for a quarterback just because they got
the fourth pick in the draft and maybe
you'll never be here again
you know i was told he was not going to
make that pick into something that hey i
like this guy a lot he's gonna have to
love a quarterback at number four in
order to take him and mike that's why in
my opinion if i am guessing right now
i think they're gonna take either you
know the tight end for florida kyle
pitts or
whichever wide receiver they're madly in
love with
that's just my that's that's my gut
feeling
they've tinkered a bit with matt ryan's
contract his cap number this year 26.9
million but next year it goes to 48.6
million if he's on the team if they cut
him or trade him they're looking at
about i'm doing the math here they're
looking at about 36 million in dead
money that they're gonna have to deal
with next year but it's either 48 you
know you're i think after this year
you're either renewing your vows with
matt ryan on a long-term deal
or you're cutting him or trading him i
don't think you can carry a 48 million
dollar cap charge into 2022 because the
caps not going to be dramatically higher
than this year because the pandemic
losses will persist and you're right
it's going to be about 9 10 million a
year for a young guy
and uh
hey the other option is trade down
that look one of the one of the reasons
that you do all the work on the
quarterbacks that may be there at four
is so you can best negotiate the value
of that pick when it's time to talk
turkey about trey lance you know
everything there is to know about trey
lance you've been scouting him and you
may draft him that's also part of the
leverage hey you don't want to trade up
he ain't going to be there when you pick
he's not going to slip through the
cracks we're taking him so when you look
at a team that really feels like it
needs
an influx of young talent
one way to do it peter move down and get
more lottery tickets
i i couldn't agree more and in that
particular situation
um especially especially mike
if washington chicago or new england you
know new england 15 washington 19
chicago 20 if they are desperate to get
one of those quarterbacks you know
that they are going to have to basically
ruin
their next couple of drafts in order to
do so at the very least ruin the 2022
draft and so
if you are
you know it's so fascinating to me
because if you're the falcons and you
determine
that let's just say you know we think we
can trade down to x
and get a really good player there from
a pool of these four or five guys
would you do that if it meant
that you had two additional first round
picks
in the next two drafts
i think that's something that terry
fontenot
has to
absolutely has to consider not that i
think it's going to happen but it could
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports